[Applaudissements]
voilà un documentaire qui depuis sa
sortie hier fait beaucoup parler un
documentaire qui s'appelle hold-up hold
up
il faut le voir entièrement financé de
façon indépendante par des cagnottes en
ligne ce document choc autour du devis
de 19 et polémiques présenté comme un
film citoyen ce film réalisé par pierre
barnérias s'en prend directement au
traitement médiatique autour de
l'épidémie
n'hésitant pas à brocarder lci et bfm tv
que vous écoutiez bfm que vous écoutiez
france info chaîne publique chaîne
privée même pensé même discours des
avocats des médecins des sociologues
prennent la parole dans ce doc sulfureux
le masque ne sert à rien quand vous
n'êtes pas malade
chaque fois que nous perdons une part de
liberté on le retrouve plus que de
nombreux responsables politiques
considèrent que ce documentaire est de
nature complotistes de son côté l'ancien
ministre de la santé philippe
douste-blazy qui lui même interviewé
dans le documentaire tient à prendre ses
distances
je n'ai pas vu ce film et s'il ya le
moindre caractère complotistes je veux
dire le plus clairement possible que je
mens désolidarise mais sur les réseaux
sociaux des milliers de messages
affluent pour soutenir ce film qui fait
état d'un complot mondial concernant le
govic 19
c'est un objectif politique ce noir
médical des internautes pas toujours
anonymes comme l'actrice sophie marceau
qui a par exemple fait la promotion de
hold up
les commentaires des internautes sont
nombreux à soutenir ce qu'elle considère
être du militantisme contre la pensée
unique
un film qui aurait déjà été vue par des
centaines de milliers d'internautes
un combat entre fake noé vérité
scientifique qui nous rappelle que la
défiance et les complots ont le vent en
poupe en ce moment alors old faut-il
censurer le dock choc sur la colline et
on aura la réaction de mounir mahjoubi 1
et bien sûr est la députée la résolution
et ancien ministre du numérique qui me
dira qu'il a repensé 2
de ce documentaire alors faut-il naturel
documentaire choc sur la copie je
pensais bien que gilles verdez allez
dire non un bien entendu j'aimerais
écouter des gens sérieux également des
personnes sérieuses également comme
nicolas pernikoff alors d'abord je suis
extrêmement choquée parce que quand vous
regardez des propos qui ont été tenus
entre de monique pinçon-charlot je sais
pas si vous avez bien sûr alors elle dit
que c'est une troisième guerre mondiale
c'est une troisième guerre mondiale
c'est la guerre de classe women les
riches contre les pauvres de la planète
c'est ça comme les nazis allemands l'ont
fait pendant la 2 la guerre la deuxième
guerre il ya l'holocauste qui va
éliminer la partie la plus pauvre de
l'humanité c'est à dire trois milliards
500 millions d'êtres humains mais là on
est tombé la folie lorsqu'il faut savoir
parce que philippe douste-blazy parler
juste avant il supplie j'ai bien
évidemment il était invité
quand je vais vous dire l'invitation
qu'ils ont lancée quand même puisque
j'ai récupéré des mails d'invitation et
10hoo voulons vraiment un film
inattaquable ça c'est la première la
première chose il y aura bien sûr des
scientifiques français mais aussi
italiens des américains souci des danois
et des italiens alors qu' à personne
donc c'est juste scandaleux
et effectivement il faut qu'il soit ce
remake de celui du tanet à bruit on
dirait qu'on est dans la nature toujours
des animaux drift tapis dans l'ombre la
fugace gens mais si on pouvait arranger
ça c'est très bon jeu c'est pas possible
oui gilles verdez bien sûr que non il
faut pas que sang sueur et alors là haut
nicolas a raison c'est sur le côté
oui c'est vrai qu'à une théorisation
d'extrême droite derrière quelques
témoignages il faut les virer
mais le reste cyril on en discute a ici
récemment ce virus
il a peut-être il a peut-être il est
peut être parti d'un laboratoire en
chine maintenant le dis donc toutes les
théories vous jugez complotite elles
sont remises en cause aujourd'hui il
faut voir ce documentaire parce qu'il a
peut-être raison c'est pas complotistes
c'est simplement faire la part du vrai
show voilà je trouve qu'il faut bien sûr
pas saturé il faut pas laisser les
choses et quand on voit effectivement ce
qui est dit dans le documentaire
moi je suis content tout ce qui compose
et aux contraintes faut le voir pour se
rendre compte puisque allart me dit sur
le coup vite voilà alors c'est vrai faux
documentaire le gouvernement est
régulièrement pris pour cible et il ya
le port du masque également qui est
remis en question
selon le radiologue pascal trotta il n'y
aura absolument aucun intérêt à porter
ces masses regard des messins qui appose
les masques aux gens qui ne sont pas
malades sont des gens foutres ce sont
des médecins de molière c'est reprendre
la fameuse pièce de jules romains le
docteur knock qui dit tout bien portant
est un malade qui s'ignore
le rôle des médecins n'est pas de dire à
la population mais tu es un masque en
plein été quand il fait 30 pour éviter
la dissémination du virus
le masque ne sert à rien tant vous
n'êtes pas malade
alors c'est un film qui dérange puisque
facebook a censuré justement la
communication des équipes du freemont
donc pour certains c'est
conspirationnistes et pour d'autres
comme sophie marceau c'est un élan de
lucidité direction qui habituellement
très discrète n'a pas hésité à la
promotion
il ya douze mille personnes qui ont
financé ce film on en est déjà à 200
milles
180 3000 euros alors oui jusqu'à preuve
du contraire ce film un seul saut nobel
de médecine
donc mon avis on est très content mais
je le garde fou et deux camps les
périodes son trouble c'est déjà ça de la
part de jamie ciel bah quoi parce que il
titille il critique que sophie martz
toits déserts
c'est pas uniquement de déminer aimé lui
critiqueurs roules tu m'as wii qui vient
qui viendrait bientôt passer outre les
pertes quand les périodes sont troublés
il faut toujours chercher les coupables
ce n'est pas être malade il faut
coupable donc des coupables c'est qu'ils
vivent des puissants contre le peuple
on tire toujours c'est toujours des
lubies levier tarte à la crème moi je
suis pour ne pas mettre des
documentaires comme star qui devait sur
des plateformes payantes c'est robert
vous commercial alors la fuite et c'est
tout regardez la réaction de mire le
match j'oublie en exclusivité pour
touche pas à mon poste
regardez il rassure ancien ministre du
numérique et député la république en
marche dans ce documentaire on vous dit
que la science vous manqués dans ses
documentaires aux boutiques le
gouvernement de j ai ne travaille que
dans l'intérêt des plus puissants et des
plus riches berthez c'est de vous dire
en fait c'est un groupe de personnes
dans le monde la qui ne cherchent qu'une
chose c'est s'enrichir et exterminer les
plus pros c'est à cause de ce
documentaire les gens refusent de
vacciner sa cause documentaire les gens
ne prennent plus aucune responsabilité
aucune distance et tu continues tu
propagé comme but partout alors ce
documentaire il a rompu le parc de
liberté d'expression et il met en danger
des vies
je crois qu'il faut faire très attention
que tu ne souhaites hauteur de sa
responsabilité
nicolas il a d'autres mais c'est bien
sûr que s'il a totalement raison mais
est ce que vous imaginez aujourd'hui il
ya tu n'es que l'incivilité où il ya des
gens qui eux refusent de mettre le
masque
il ya des gens qui refusent plein de
choses vous rendez compte que ce que
peut véhiculer ce genre de documentaire
auprès des gens alors et d'ailleurs on
est dans le complot dans le doute on
laisse tout tomber on vit normalien et
je vais montrer un extrait qui a fait
énormément parler c'est l'extrait où ils
disent que c'est la déclaration du
professeur jean bernard four tillon qui
explique que le virus ne serait pas
originaire de yuan mais de l'institut
pasteur il insinue qu'il aurait été
fabriqué regardez
il n'est pas dangereuse mais il est il
un peu plus dangereux que que le combat
virus naturel si on a foutu les
saloperies mais c'est pas dangereux
qu'est thriller je veux c'est le vaccin
qui va en sortir
tout a été fait cas pas su pasteur pour
le professeur aucun doute le virus est
bien sorti de l'institut pasteur avant
d'être envoyé à ioane ou ailleurs le
coupable de lakovic 19 a bien été trouvé
en plein confinement à prix nobel de
médecine intervient pour le dire
réaction attendue des journalistes
présents est-ce que vous annoncez est
énorme c'est une c'est une bombe
nucléaire si je puis dire et vous méfier
les deux vont pourtant enterrer
l'information oui moi je veux dire un
petit truc quand même
jenlain mystiquement c'est tout ce que
je déteste moi je suis contre la censure
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis mon insu mais
ça parle d'un truc est odieux c'est à
dire sa part de la thèse au départ qu'il
y à un complot dont tout va être dit
dedans pour convaincre rien composé non
audités sont éteintes déroulée comme ça
quand vous allez voir une course à
longchamp 8e 12 ans l'argument est plus
de force aux contrats aussi là c'est la
prof de philo qui parraine en isolement
cela développe
oui 27 pour son nom 73% rien et oui on
peut tout d'accord avec vous mais moi ce
que je pense c'est que c'est c'est
important aussi de prendre l'avis de
tout le monde et c'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment il ya beaucoup de gens qui
pensent au complot de plus en plus donc
après bas et on arrivait qu'on aurait
plusieurs listes et donner son avis